they say this is hands down the best
first sentence of a math problem some
dude wants two rectangular enclosures
against his house for some reason he has
600 meters of fencing find the area in
terms of X the maximum area and the
dimensions of the maximum area
since we have a rectangle enclosure each
of these sides will be equal to X then
they're 600 meters of fencing so the
other side is 600 minus 3x the area will
be the product of these Dimensions which
is X multiplied by 600 minus 3x to get
the maximum area we expand this out
factor a negative 3 then we complete the
square by adding and subtracting 100
squared we do a little bit of algebra
here now we're subtracting 3 times a
square term so we minimize the square
term which happens at x equals 100 and
so the maximum area will be thirty
thousand finally we need the dimensions
X is equal to 100 the other side is 600
minus 3x which equals 300 so the
dimensions are 100 by 300 meters